hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the My
Little Pony containment breach mod okay
we're almost at the end but I have to
make a disclaimer for you guys I will
never watch My Little Pony I know a lot
of you are like oh I hope Markab are
macabre barber no I'm just gonna crush
your dreams right now I'm never ever
ever going to watch it and that's never
gonna change
I'm not nor will I ever be a brony so
stop asking I am NOT hi [ __ ] out
Wow you go to hell and you die
you go to hell and you die ha ha ha I am
too smart for you I am tempura pizza fat
to sea
no thank you alright I'm probably
getting you too
that is actually three bodies or one
really messed up guy Wow you following
me you're [ __ ] me a [ __ ] get out of
here
oh thank you I'm pissed off that guy
[ __ ] close the damn garden what happened
what how can I be back here no [ __ ]
way
no way no it's a big [ __ ] jerk-off
wait hang on there had to be another way
that I passed by because I was running
scared right oh [ __ ] where are you
Rainbow Dash ah I thought so
yeah you suck so much good thing I have
this thing of super running it awfully
nice I'm glad I spent the extra time to
get the okay this way yeah this way
no there's my grunts stock I thought I
contained you you [ __ ] or did I knit
those in a different episode and I
didn't actually do it [ __ ] I gotta go
the other way then or maybe hopefully
there's another way that I can go I
don't really know at this point ah
Pass okay alright let's take this off
let's close this door so nothing sticks
up behind me and pokes me into bartók's
had turn on front to be poked into
bartók's concurring runs what do you do
I know know why do I have two of these
nope nope no no no okay no aah
Rock ah man I got the burn note I guess
but that doesn't really help me I've
heard he's he activated the warheads
I've already done everything how can
this be a babe frickin circle there's
nowhere else to go there must have been
something that I missed
hang on more dark running here I'm
running into the depths of Hell right
now dog paws are me I'm a little on
as due to the fact that ponies want to
murder me where the hell is gate B I
know gate B has got to be around here
somewhere because that whatever that
computer goat thing was it opened the
gate B cuz I did what it asked right
right right and I can't possibly be back
in this stupid place it all just loops
in us wait is escapee was this gate B no
it's not gate B it's not gate B at all
this is not gate B maybe one of the
other ones that would look like this was
gay be more dark running okay I gotta go
through down here ooh
how is hate going down here hi hey go
[ __ ] off where are you there you are I
see Joey died in a fire
how'd you get in there already you're
such up you're such an a-hole where are
you hey you're okay predictable spot
don't move ha don't move
good stay that way okay I know we've
been through here multiple times before
and I don't know what good it's gonna do
me because I just feel like I'm running
in circles over and over again that's to
the computer person I don't think he's
gonna talk to me anymore but maybe you
will maybe he's got something to say to
me hello nope you're turned off you
don't care about me you don't care about
anybody but yourself you're stupid 8-bit
computer intelligence I can't see a damn
thing
I just want to go fast right now so
thank you very much this is where the
two new scps were was was that I'd never
heard those footsteps before I've gone
this way and this way I've already gone
down there there's the weird stacked
people for the Omega warhead silo
this leads end up with Rainbow Dash's
place I've already contained Rainbow
Dash didn't I thought I did maybe I did
not seriously what's going on with it
did I go down there hello
did I go down here
what the hell what what just happened
what is happened what the hell what else
happened hang on what did I just fall
through the world I can't see anything
so this isn't gonna help me budge huh
what the hell just happened what the
bugs in this game are rather pervasive I
believe that the original game hasn't
been updated recently because the person
who makes it is like deployed in Iraq or
something so blame the war stop the war
continue SCP containment breach
development so that we can get these
bugs out of here whatever they may be
or make up better damn Pony mod oh no
pick one other two I don't really know I
don't really care which one you pick
ah BAM ah what cut oh wait hang on it
whoa what the what the hell happened
what happened there why did it suddenly
beside to be good okay
stay out of that room okay we're good
we're not falling through I thought I've
been down here one night I think the
only way that I don't know
oh no I thought I've been down here
maybe not
these are still on okay so now they are
off and I can continue on with my life
right right uh-huh wait where's it wait
where's the elevator button oh no that
doesn't sound good
that doesn't sound good at all
why wha-wha-wha alright screw this I'm
no clipping here do we go hello wah wah
wah I'm going up right
what the hell I know I'm in pitch black
two sisters all night
no clip you were supposed to save our
people not Caspian to do what da hell oh
ha ha ha ha ha ok gimme Kenya you just
stay over there and help off
oh can you stay over there aah aah
what the hell was I do not know what the
warheads are off now you stay in there
and die ok Oh clip off don't be
Dobin I got up totally legitimate
totally legitimate totally legitimate
toe smick scrotes legitimate
okay so I'm close to where I was
oh [ __ ] off shut up damn you Pinkie Pie
Oh God I'm starting to hate ponies more
and more just just hate them no Pinkie
Pie move your fat ass
God stop eating so many damn cupcakes or
whatever you ponies eat
I guess I'm exercise God okay thank you
get out of my way
huh man y'all so back okay alright
we are out of there and we're going
somewhere else where I don't really know
where I've been here a million for
Jillian time how is that fair I looked
in the hole you're not there
baki Oh
oh it it this [ __ ] OS pony where are
you are you behind me or in front of me
am I going backwards I thought I'd
mobile task force you at cloud nine has
entered the facility all remaining
survivors are advised to stay in
evacuation shelters or any safe area
facility okay whatever scoring personnel
out when you escape LTS have been
contained okay yeah whatever I don't
care okay there are two other doors here
that I have not seen yet this is not
gate B I cannot go through it but that
means that the other door must lead to
the exit right I know you can't can't
see anything just yet but hi
hello Rainbow Dash can you go away now
thank you
yeah where am I
wait please tell me this is like Gabey
or some gate hey that's not gate B I
want to go through key hey I don't even
know this is Ed or this is some this is
one of the exits I don't care it's an
exit hey look it's cuz I didn't contain
him or something I don't remember so who
cares it's an ending go get him go go go
be induced to someone else besides me
the friendship cannon hahahaha I'm just
doing this cuz I need to be able to run
now ah wait what's this way Oh what the
hell
that heat Busey
yeah too bad rainbow [ __ ] hat golden
rainbow [ __ ] her him her what was that
I saw some aah oh no no too much trouble
game you're coming with us okay
yay finally done done
done
done I'm done I am done My Little Pony
mod is done shop I want to do my damn
outro are you know what I'm just gonna
turn him down all right I'm done with my
little pony mod forever don't ever ever
expect me to play it ever ever ever ever
again D it is the end for all time all
of time I will never play the SCP call
me odd ha ha ha ha
alright so hope you enjoyed it so far
even those of you who are not vids My
Little Pony hope it was enjoyable for
you I am NOT a fan of My Little Pony I
still thought it wasn't good buddy so
take it for what it is it's just
complete silliness so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
Turner
Oh
I could probably